hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Medina here to bringing this
week's review of arrow season 2 episode
7 keep your enemies closer so we've got
some new reveals this week again this
just so many comin it's long too much
right I'm no threat yeah off and be like
wait what's going on well and that's the
thing i love the fact that we mentioned
this before how they're just expanding
the D scene yes its season two and I
love that I mean we got introduced to
hive which I'm really excited about
saying you know an amanda waller Amanda
Waller Justice League just like the
animated series the comic book she's all
kind of hot you played by Cynthia
addai-robinson from Spartacus good she
just be a little bit bigger a little bit
or older woman I guess it depends on 52
kind of your change Oh sexy you know
it's the newest of relaunch so I don't
know where to start I guess let's start
with the first thing that's important is
that we wanted more Diggle yeah yeah we
got a lot more Diggle this was an angle
centered episode even though was a lot
of other stuff going on yeah I got admit
like I know a lot of you guys you know
mention that you thought maybe this
episode might be a filler episode and I
go I kind of thought that too and I was
pleasantly surprised that it wasn't i
was i I really loved it I thought it was
a lot of fun I thought the whole Diggle
back story was actually really
interesting right I like that when he
actually was confronted with Deadshot
they ended up killing each other it was
a great say yes I was like you know what
I didn't kill your brother but I'm just
a guy for hire like it's not like i'm
priming personal against your brother
niggles like who are you hive you're
like hey you rip off the top of your
head what hive stands for haha hierarchy
wait hold on I got it we had to say this
is probably higher key of international
vengeance and extermination and
everybody anything simple right exactly
so this is a new organizations or
criminal organization there's so much
going ok so we have we know at the
League of Assassins last week yes Rachel
Poole is somewhere in the background
doing all these things we have brother
blood a couple episodes ago now now we
have hive hey so it's their sense
something up for something big it's
definitely gonna be and we saw the flash
coming sometime later on in the season I
mean there's just so much going on I
guess the next thing we'll talk about is
um I guess Oliver in his little you know
relationships going on there with ya
that was weird yeah a little weird I
like the idea of him and felicity you
know what I mean but I just felt like
they were like on set up
mean aside from a couple of references
she might have made about like watching
a workout or whatever like Harper we
like I think it deserve better I'm like
really hey he's a little set up to it
and nothing wrong with what's her name's
you know summer blouse yeah ah she's
businesswoman she's smart speaks Russian
who have to make sure she was really fun
in this episode yeah I like the road I
like the fact that she started to play a
slightly bigger role I don't know how
much bigger it's gonna get but I mean
she was fun she was kind of like a pain
in Oliver side you know what I mean kind
of tagging tagging along in the trip so
yeah she was good it was good and then
he does one relationship grows another
falls apart poor Thea you know it looks
like she's kind of forced to give up you
know our good buddy yeah I'm not gonna
lie there are there are moments when I
kind of like and with their relationship
like I kind of lose interest and I maybe
that's just because they're not really
focusing that much about Roy which I
understand you know you want to kind of
build that up a little bit right leg
straight and kind of you know fleshing
him out and stuff but at times you know
the relationship is whatever sometimes
my goal I kind of tuned out yeah man
it's like Roy in Thea Athena's really
had much to do she's more of like a go
like I guess the she's the one person
doesn't have no superpowers but doesn't
have like any big did you go run the
role of that yes exactly like and I
think that was just to give her
something to do right to be dating Roy
who is we all hope becomes red arrow
Arsenal whatever happens I mean so but I
mean still it's still entertaining they
don't focus too much about how big it
was absolutely and I'm really happy to
see that Sarah you know yeah black
Canary's still a part of the show and if
it's just some flashbacks which is great
because we're going to see a little bit
more of her backstory alright and we
also got to see a little man who banette
even though it was just briefed yes
basic not even lat maybe two episodes a
while ago I saw it is all I'm yeah her
and now we know what's going on with
them yeah we should explain like you
know could explain the mask you know
just their face being burned and stuff
but I'm really liking the pace of the
show I think they're still doing a great
job in like every single episode has
consistently been good interesting you
don't unfortunately they're a lot of
shows out there they can't say that but
this shows definitely one of them if
this show struggles from anything and
again this is a little over exaggeration
when I put it in league with show like
me like Game of Thrones or mad but not
in the same sense it's much worse it's
that good what I mean is that
there's just so many characters you want
to spend time with because we never get
enough of these characters like I want
more Deathstroke I want more Diggle I'll
even take little Felicity see what she's
up to and one more I mean there's always
I want more but something shows fault
it's all week or just that they're cast
is huge now oh absolutely and I hope
that that won't turn into a bad thing
because you know sometimes when shells
just get like clustered so many
different actors and different
characters and stuff that could kind of
hurt a show right you know so but it
seems to me like they're doing a good
job of really easing into this universe
and wounding with expanding and
everything I was gonna want to talk
about one more thing here I like that
dr. Ivo kind of explain why they're
there on the island so I guess with this
little history lesson about how the
Americans have had the manhattan project
with the atomic bomb and the Germans had
their thing and now the Japanese had
some type of serum or something they
were working on a venom yeah maybe or
what cuz amazed owes half like he's at
party Android and yeah it's kind of like
you know adaptive adaptive yeah so I'm
yeah I like that we got a little history
with their I mean they're really doing a
good job even those a lot to take in
explained everything absolutely
absolutely and again like I said this is
definitely become one of my favorite
shows on yeah and just like the
characters all remain interesting you
know aside from my little gripe with
like the whole theory yeah every
character has been interested but I mean
that's what we thought of this week's
episode I mean what do you think about
you know all the stuff that's going on
right now with high ratio ghoul Amazo
doctor I was almost like Jack much going
on but it's good too much yeah so you
got some new characters as we bless all
you think has always been compelled us
on think here calm you also can check us
out of this YouTube page watch our
videos it's think you're a pro we're
also on Twitter vintage of michael
dennis any of us asked this question
cells but what you're watching it's at
think hero i'm at griffin de and i'm at
mr. michael Alexis and we also have a
facebook page at facebook.com slash
think hero fans and come you know spread
the word give us a like you know on this
video subscribe just you know spread the
word about think hero you know and let
us know maybe you got some other videos
or the shows you're passionate about let
us know if you want to review those and
yeah check out next week
you